you don't have to be on social media for
long before you come across a spam bot
sometimes these fake accounts randomly
comment on your photos
maybe they're trying to slide into your
dms perhaps they just want to follow you
when you first get the notification they
seem like normal people but they're not
so what are these spam bots and why do
they interact with us could interacting
with these fake people have real
consequences i spoke with some social
media and cyber security experts to find
out how spam bots work where they come
from and what you can do to try to stop
them
so what exactly is a spambot you've
probably seen them they might look
something like this if you look at their
username you might see a long string of
numbers attached or the accounts might
be attached to spammy links
post-promising free stuff or adult
content they evolve over time but are
basically the result of computer
programs designed to look like humans
while executing repetitive actions in
other words they look like real humans
but they're not and they do the same
thing over and over again and there are
a ton of them out there bots made up
more than 40 of internet traffic in
2020. that means a lot of internet
activity is coming from bots anyone with
basic programming knowledge can make
them i mean after all creating a social
media account only requires a couple of
steps and it's easy to strip someone
else's info online or just make up
details yourself if you've seen someone
you know pop up in bot form it's because
spambots can copy a legitimate person's
profile photo and name they also access
people's accounts through compromised
passwords and email addresses you might
be wondering why spambots exist in the
first place while some were designed to
spread misinformation or for political
agendas a lot of times the goal is to
make money if you click on one of their
spammy links somebody might be trying to
profit off of the click there's also a
long list of companies offering fake
followers for cash so should you be
afraid of spam bots what's really at
stake if you engage with them mark
ostrowski a cyber security expert at
checkpoint says you could lose your
whole account if you give them enough
information and really the worst case
scenario is that you actually click and
interact with these bots not knowingly
and either give out personal information
or click on a phishing link or somehow
surrender credentials that could be used
for an attack or to gain access to your
accounts or you could lose access to
your computer if you click on a link and
get a virus from them that means
anything you have saved on your computer
would be up for grabs and that includes
your banking information photos you name
it but even if they don't defraud you
they could damage your reputation like i
said they might make a fake social media
account using your information or
picture this you're on instagram live
but bots are spamming your feed with
links to adult content that could be
embarrassing i reached out to facebook
instagram and tick tock to find out what
they're doing to slow down these bots
each of them didn't respond
we all know that spam bots are out there
we all know that they're a nuisance but
what i really wanted to find out was how
we can stop them or at least slow them
down a little bit experts told me there
are basically four lines of defense
number one avoid social media which i
don't know about you but i know i'm not
gonna do that because how on earth am i
gonna keep in touch with my friends and
family you can try that but i know it's
not gonna work for me number two make
your account private that's a little bit
more realistic for a lot of us bots like
to impersonate social media accounts
that have a lot of followers and that
are public if your photos are private
it's hard for them to steal them and
being private also keeps bots from
commenting on your content number three
don't engage even if you're private
they'll probably still try to dm you but
those messages are often filtered into
another inbox anyway and they're pretty
easy to ignore i treat them just like
spamming my email delete the comments
when possible or just ignore them being
on social media comes with inherent
risks but accidentally following the bot
version of someone you know probably
shouldn't be one of them number four
block and report them it won't keep more
from trying but hey it's worth a shot if
you have the time and another thing some
of the accounts that you think might be
a bot might not be some people barely
post on social media and others create
accounts just to troll if it's a twitter
profile you're wondering about there are
services like bottle meter and bot site
that will try to tell you if an account
is likely a bot but frankly you can't
always be so sure
if you want to share your experience
with spambots leave a comment and don't
forget to like and subscribe we'll talk
soon